there are parts of the world where death
is an illusion I've been to one
I learned to be very convincing hey
youtubers it's Charlie this week on
arrow
maura finally went free oliver ended up
killing count vertigo we find out why
that hosen that oliver always carried
around was so important and Malcolm
Merlyn is back so there's a whole bunch
of stuff going on now I also have news
about next week's midseason finale the
debut of the flash as well as someone
that's been cast as Nyssa al Ghul the
daughter of Ra's al Ghul it's not Talia
let's talk about our favorite moments
then I'll do my review and then I'll
talk about what's coming in the next
couple of weeks so bombshell Malcolm
Merlyn is not dead obviously the last
couple of minutes of that episode were
the most important we're not really sure
what he's going to be doing but
obviously he just wanted to get Moira
out of prison his quote was really
really important I've been to parts of
the world where death is only an
illusion
obviously he's talking about a Lazarus
Pit but if you are a Doctor Who fan like
me as you can tell by the thousands of
Doctor Who videos I've been doing on my
channel lately he is Captain Jack who is
immortal and cannot die it's just a nice
little reference for all of us fans just
because it's the 50th anniversary this
week I'm sure number 2 Thea is Malcolm's
daughter isn't it funny how the two
biggest moments came from the same scene
in all honesty whenever he announced
that Thea was actually his daughter I
thought he was gonna say Oliver I feel
like that would actually been a bigger
twist let me know if you thought the
same thing though but wouldn't it be
cool if Malcolm really was Oliver's
father having an evil father wasn't
there some sort of sci-fi franchise that
did that star wars something I can't
remember I did not think that Felicity
would escape count vertigo without
getting dosed with whatever he was
giving everyone her being infected would
just put her more on the path to
becoming that Oracle character I totally
bought Oliver killing him though to save
Felicity I totally bought that he would
kill someone to save her and who does
not think that he totally deserved to
die that weird accent that he had was
just way too comic book II I feel like
arrow does take itself a little bit
seriously so if a character comes on it
does do a funny voice like that they are
probably gonna die pretty soon let me
know if you got the count vertigo Dark
Knight Joker reference so if you
remember way back in 2007 they released
a viral teaser for Dark Knight Joker
basically took a hostage put him on
shaky cam for the whole world to see and
then made him read the camera I totally
guessed the count vertigo brother blood
connection early in the episode but it
was not clear as to whether or not he
wanted count vertigo to start dosing
everyone and making them sick that
that survived brother Bloods treatment
at the end of the episode that serum is
basically going to be this crazy per
soldier in the next episode but that's
going to be part of the flash storyline
so I'll talk about that after I do my
review back on the island we find out
what the hose is all about it's
basically just coordinates to get to the
Super Soldier Serum obviously they're
gonna use that to save slate and I think
that that is going to be when he starts
to turn into the real Deathstroke the
Slade Wilson Deathstroke but because
they're enemies in the comics they
obviously have to have a big falling-out
at some point so I'm guessing that
either shadow is going to die or the
Super Soldier Serum is going to drive
Slade mad but what did I think of the
episode overall so this was an amazing
episode and I totally expected it to be
terrible the title made you think that
it was gonna be all about this trial but
it was almost not about the trial it was
all about what was going on around the
trial Malcolm Merlyn brother blood and
Deathstroke on the island it's still not
my favorite episode my favorite episode
is still the Russian road trip from last
week but obviously next week's
mid-season finale is probably going to
change that because we're gonna get the
flash we have Deathstroke Malcolm Merlyn
is back and brother blood is probably
going to do something big I say it all
the time but I totally love how arrow is
not afraid to make all these DC Universe
references and kind of make these
character leaps and developing so fast
though with that in mind here are the
details on Barry Allen and the flash in
the next episode brother Bloods super
soldier that guy from the end of that
episode is basically going to go on a
rampage he's going to try and take out
the particle accelerator and in that
explosion Barry Allen will get his super
speed he's not going to put on the red
flash costume until part two of the
season next year but he will get
SuperSpeed he will basically become the
flash if that weren't enough arrow also
announced the casting of a new character
called Nyssa al Ghul the daughter of
Ra's al Ghul
so she in the comic books is like a half
daughter that Ra's al Ghul had with a
Russian woman for a minute I thought it
might be Summer Glau but obviously they
cast a different actress so that still
means that Summer Glau could be Talia al
Ghul I'll talk more about her in future
videos because she's probably going to
debut until the second half of the
season so it's gonna be a while before
we see her but let me know what your
favorite moment from the episode was and
how surprised are you that Malcolm
Merlyn is back on the show now in the
mid-season finale let me know what
you're really looking forward to what
you think is going to happen with this
Barry Allen flash
obviously we have so many plots that
it's going to start tying up we have the
flash we have Slade Wilson the
Deathstroke we have Malcolm Merlyn and
we have brother blood all those things
are going to come to a head next week
right now click here to get my video for
last week's episode of arrow and click
here to learn all about the
special stuff I'm doing for Doctor Who
with my friends we got a big thing
coming this Saturday and I'm going to
make it on to BBC America's Channel
that's right it's gonna be my face on TV
Italy crazy but thanks for watching I'll
see you guys tomorrow high fives
you